>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: YOU COULD HAVE SEEN
THIS COMING.
DR. SUESS ONE OF THE MOST
BELOVED CHILDREN'S AUTHORS.
AN AMERICAN, BUT HIS BOOKS WERE
WRITTEN BEFORE 2008 SO SOMEONE
CALLED THEM RACIST.
THEY CLAIM RACISM SPANS ACROSS
THE DR. SUESS BOOKS.
THE ARGUMENT IS THAT HIS
CHARACTERS ARE TOO MALE AND HAVE
THE WRONG SKIN COLOR.
MARK STEIN JOINS US.
WHAT WERE THE SKIN COLORS IN DR.
SUESS?
>> THEY DID A SURVEY AND
CONCLUDED ONLY 2% OF THE
CHARACTERS IN DR. SUESS ARE
PERSONS OF COLOR AND THAT'S A
PROBLEM.
I FIND THE WORLD PROBLEMATIC
PROBLEMATIC,  BECAUSE IT'S A WAY
FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE WARRIORS TO
LABEL ANYTHING THEY DON'T LIKE
WITHOUT ENGAGING IT IN A
COHERRENT WAY.
THERE MAY BE REASONS ONLY 2% OF
CHARACTERS IN DR. SUESS ARE
PERSON OF COLOR.
THERE ARE NOT SAME-SEX MARRIAGE
IN JANE AUSTEN.
AUTHORS ARE ENTITLED TO WRITE
ABOUT THE CHARACTERS THEY WANT
TO RIGHT ABOUT.
LIVING NOVELISTS, THE BEST
SELLING AMERICAN NOVELIST
SCRIBEER TOLD ME BECAUSE SHE
WRITES ABOUT WOMEN WHO ARE NOT
WHITE LIKE HERSELF.
IF A WHITE WOMAN WRITES IN THE
VOICE OF A BLACK MAN SHE IS
CULTURALLY APPROPRIATING.
YOU CAN'T WIN EITHER WAY.
WHAT THESE CULTURE VANDALS ARE
DOING TRYING TO MAKE US LIVE IN
A PERMANENT YEAR ZERO AS THEY
CALLED IT IN CAMBODIA.
WE HAVE NO CULTURE INHERITANCE.
>> Tucker: NO ART IS BEING
CREATED BECAUSE IT CAN'T BE.
I THOUGHT OF YOU WHEN I READ
THIS.
THE WORLD'S BEST BRIDGE PLAYER
GOT BUSTED FOR DOPING.
HIS NAME WAS GREG.
HE WAS SUSPENDED AFTER A TEST
FOUND ELEVATED TESTOSTERONE
LEVELS.
ARE YOU SURPRISED THERE IS
DOPING IN BRIDGE?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
BRIDGE IS RENOWNED FOR THE USE
OF PERFORMANCE ENHANCING DRUGS.
EVERYBODY'S GRANDMA IS ON
STEROIDS AND TESTOSTERONE IN THE
BRIDGE FOURS.
IT'S TERRIBLE.
I HAD A PROBLEM WITH IT TOO.
I WAS PLAYING SOLITAIRE WITH
MYSELF AND I REALIZED I TOOK
PERFORMANCE ENHANCING DRUGS.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHING].
>> ALL OF THESE.
YOU GO TO ANY SENIOR CENTER IN
FLORIDA AND TRACES OF URINE ARE
FOUND IN THEIR DRUG SAMPLES.
THIS IS THE WORLD WE LIVE IN.
PERFORMANCE ENHANCING DRUGS FOR
BRIDGE FOURS.
THAT'S WHY IT'S POURING ACROSS
THE BORDER.